Buonasera a tutti. Dunque, in questi tre incontri che mi sono stati affidati quest'anno, mi
allontano un po' da quelli che sono i miei temi soliti e, come dire, è un'excusazio
non petita con cui devo cominciare. Io non mi occupo di mestiere di storia del risorgimento,
di mestiere mi occupo di storia medievale, con qualche incursione nella storia militare
magari un po' più vicina a noi, ma degli argomenti di cui vi parlerò in queste serate non mi
sono mai occupato professionalmente e gran parte delle cose che vi racconterò in queste
sere le ho imparate anch'io nei mesi scorsi preparando queste lezioni. Subito ero un po' incerto
se accettare un incarico del genere, poi mi è sembrato che nell'aria ci fosse comunque
voglia di parlare di queste cose. Non mi sembra che ci sia quella gran voglia di celebrare,
mi sembra che la macchina delle celebrazioni ufficiali non stia coinvolgendo così fortemente
le persone, anche se forse è una mia impressione, ma di parlare, ragionare, capire meglio, conoscere
meglio quell'epoca, soprattutto conoscere meglio quella gente e provare a capire perché hanno fatto
quello che hanno fatto, provare a capire magari prima di schierarsi e giudicare a priori in base
alle nostre posizioni ideologiche. Di questo mi pare ci sia voglia. Troppe scuse, basta, cominciamo.
Cavour, sono tre serate, tre personaggi, i tre uomini che hanno preso le decisioni cruciali in
quegli anni a metà dell'Ottocento. Cavour, il re Vittorio Emanuele II, Garibaldi. Per un momento
ci eravamo chiesti se non si dovesse metterci piuttosto Mazzini, piuttosto che il re magari,
che è personaggio da diversi punti di vista, di statura minore rispetto a Cavour e a Garibaldi,
ma il fatto è che questi tre sono i tre che hanno, ripeto, preso le decisioni cruciali,
che hanno assunto le iniziative decisive o perlomeno che hanno scelto di non impedire
certe iniziative e anche quello è un modo di decidere. Mazzini non ha preso nessuna decisione
cruciale. Mazzini era un condannato a morte in esilio, un pericoloso terrorista agli occhi
di molti e, benché la sua influenza sul risorgimento sia ovviamente importante, non è uno dei tre
che, ripeto, hanno fatto l'Italia in quegli anni, in quei pochissimi anni. E allora, cominciamo
da Cavour. Questi tre incontri sono tutti un po' legati l'uno all'altro. Io non esaurirò
il personaggio di Cavour questa sera, tornerò su di lui anche le prossime volte, non riuscirò
questa sera a raccontare tanti avvenimenti. Gli avvenimenti spero che verranno fuori pian
piano attraverso l'avvicinamento ai tre personaggi, ai tre uomini. Cavour nasce a Torino nel 1810,
suddito di Napoleone, suddito francese. Nasce in una Torino che è parte della Francia
napoleonica. Non è parte di quel regno d'Italia che Napoleone ha pure creato, con capitale
a Milano. No, no, il Piemonte è stato proprio, come anche altre zone, la Liguria e più tardi
anche altri pezzi d'Italia, il Piemonte è stato proprio annesso alla Francia e Cavour
nasce a Torino suddito francese. Nasce da una grande famiglia nobile, antica, di origine
medievale, non sono poi tante le famiglie nobili di origine addirittura medievale, che però
famiglia nobile di Benso di Cavour, che però si è rapidamente allineata col nuovo regime
francese. Il padre di Camillo, il marchese Michele di Cavour, è uno degli uomini più
in vista della piccola corte napoleonica di Torino, perché a Torino c'è una piccola
corte. Napoleone, dopo aver annesso il Piemonte alla Francia, ha però deciso, in omaggio proprio
a quell'aristocrazia piemontese, che aveva fatto abbastanza in fretta a mollare i Savoia
e accettare il nuovo regime. Ecco, proprio in omaggio a loro, Napoleone aveva creato
a Torino una piccola corte, mandando a Torino un governatore, il principe Camillo Borghese.
Il principe Camillo Borghese e sua moglie, che è poi la sorella di Napoleone, Paolina
Bonaparte, la bellissima, quella ritratta dal Canova sdraiata sul canapè, la più bella
donna del suo tempo. Perché vi racconto questo? Perché il marchese Michele di Cavour è uno
dei principali cortigiani del principe Borghese, è anche un grosso uomo d'affari che fa un sacco
di soldi negli anni di Napoleone. E quando nasce il piccolo, e non si sa ancora come si
chiamerà, quando nasce il bambino, che è il secondo genito, nel 1810, a fargli da padrino
chiamano proprio il principe Camillo Borghese, governatore del Piemonte. Lui è Paolina, madrina.
Ecco perché Cavour si chiama Camillo. Ed ecco perché Cavour per tutta la vita parla
meglio il francese dell'italiano. Questa è una vecchia storia, si sa che Cavour aveva
qualche difficoltà con l'italiano e lui stesso dichiarava apertamente che quanto a scriverlo
preferiva scrivere in francese. Non è perché il Piemonte sia una regione più francese delle
altre. A volte in Piemonte si coltiva un po' questa idea che il Piemonte sia in qualche
modo mezzo francese. E uno dei fatti che si citano a ricordo di questo è proprio il
fatto che uno come Cavour era molto più a suo agio col francese che non l'italiano.
Ecco in realtà è una frottola. Il Piemonte è una parte integrante d'Italia, ha sempre
avuto una storia strettamente legata a quella d'Italia, ma la generazione di Cavour è nata
in un Piemonte annesso alla Francia napoleonica. Cavour nei suoi primi anni è stato educato in
una casa dove si parlava francese, anche perché, va detto anche questo, sua madre era
svizzera, svizzera francese, e quindi è ovvio che Cavour è stato allevato con il francese
come lingua materna. Cavour fin da piccolo, si dice, dimostra il caratterino che poi dimostrerà
da grande. Anche questa è una vecchia storia, quando un uomo diventa celebre è facile che
i parenti o i vecchi amici di famiglia si ricordino gli aneddoti che dimostrano che
già da bambino in qualche modo l'uomo si vedeva già, era predestinato. Tuttavia, insomma,
uno può avere qualche dubbio, ma c'è un aneddoto raccontato da un amico di infanzia
che io vorrei ricordare. Ah, piccola parentesi, vi dicevo all'inizio che ho studiato naturalmente
per preparare questi incontri su temi che non sono i miei temi abituali. Ovviamente ho usato
il lavoro di colleghi, vorrei citare, perché l'ho usato davvero molto, almeno il bel libro
di Adriano Viarengo, Cavour, che è uscito in modo molto, come dire, con grande tempismo
proprio quest'anno e che è un libro di straordinario interesse. Ecco, proprio Viarengo racconta
un aneddoto riferito da un amico di famiglia. Cavour ha sei anni, Camillo, a sei anni va a
trovare i parenti della madre a Ginevra, amatissimi, arrivano nel castello di famiglia in un paesino
vicino a Ginevra. Il bambino è furibondo perché hanno avuto dei problemi col cambio
dei cavalli alla posta, sono arrivati in ritardo. Il bambino furibondo arriva a casa, corre
incontro al nonno e gli dice voglio che il maestro di posta sia cacciato. Il nonno gli
dice ma io non posso mica far cacciare il maestro di posta, chi lo può fare? È solo il sindaco
lo può cacciare, voglio parlare col sindaco. Allora il nonno divertito chiama il sindaco,
sono tutti amici ovviamente, gli dice ci sarebbe questo metto che vuole un'udienza. Il piccolo
Cavour ha sei anni, va dal sindaco, torna a casa trionfante e appena vede il nonno da
lontano gli fa ebbene sarà licenziato. Ecco questo Cavour, secondo quelli che lo conobbero,
è lo stesso Cavour che poi da grande farà di mestiere il primo ministro e farà l'unità
d'Italia. Abbiamo anche fonti ancora più sicure sul fatto che Cavour avesse già da
ragazzino un carattere imperioso. La famiglia lo manda all'accademia militare, dai 10 ai
15 anni Cavour, che è un figlio cadetto, ci torneremo subito su questo fatto che è
molto importante, studia all'accademia militare e nelle sue note caratteristiche viene riportato
più volte che è stato punito per l'arrogante rifiuto di obbedire agli ordini, nonché per
il tono perentorio con cui si rivolge agli altri comandando. Ecco. Ora, il personaggio
Cavour, al di là del carattere individuale che può essere più o meno pepato in ognuno
di noi, ha però un aspetto che è collegato a questa sua imperiosità e che vale la pena
di sottolineare. Io cercherò di individuare una serie di aspetti del carattere e soprattutto
dell'azione di Cavour. Sarà sempre ovviamente un quadro incompleto. Sono una serie di spunti
che propongo. Ebbene, un tratto che si rischia di dimenticare è cosa voleva dire essere un
nobile in quella Torino, in quel Piemonte del primo Ottocento. Di Cavour si dice, io questo
l'ho raccolto, non so quanto sia vero, che non avrebbe mai dato del tu a un amico che non
fosse nobile. Questo può darsi, sarà così, non sarà così. Certo è che nel Piemonte
del primo Ottocento, della restaurazione in cui Cavour cresce, c'è un'ostilità profondissima
fra la nobiltà e la borghesia. C'è un'ostilità così profonda che nel 1847, sta per scoppiare
la prima guerra di indipendenza, d'accordo? L'ambasciatore inglese a Torino manda un rapporto
a Londra dove dice, sì, qui la situazione è molto molto tesa. Secondo me qui prima o
poi scoppia la guerra civile, fra i nobili e i borghesi. Talmente profondo è il risentimento
di queste due classi. Ebbene, Cavour è un nobile fino al midollo. Alla battaglia di Goito,
la prima battaglia della prima guerra di indipendenza, cade il nipote amatissimo di Cavour. Cavour
non si è mai sposato, non ha avuto figli, torneremo anche su questo. Aveva un nipote
amatissimo, il figlio del fratello maggiore. Questo nipote, Augusto, ufficiale, cade a Goito
e Cavour, si dice, conserverà per tutta la vita in camera sua l'uniforme del nipote.
Talmente era legato a questo ragazzo e talmente è colpito dalla sua morte. Ebbene, Cavour,
a proposito della morte di Augusto alla battaglia di Goito, scrive,
non si dirà che l'aristocrazia piemontese non paghi il suo tributo alla patria. Essa
si fa uccidere sui campi, mentre gli avvocati la diffamano nei trivi e nei caffè. Ecco,
tanto appunto per questo clima di violenta opposizione fra nobiltà e borghesia, che è
il clima in cui cresce Cavour, e tanto per la sua appartenenza comunque rivendicata a
questo mondo nobiliare aristocratico. Tanto più interessante in quanto, a giudizio dei
contemporanei, magari malevoli, l'aspetto fisico di Cavour non era affatto aristocratico. Lo
conosciamo tutti Cavour, i ritratti, le statue, le biandisti tutti. Aggiungete l'abitudine di
fregarsi le mani con soddisfazione, che tutti i commentatori del tempo riportano. Ebbene,
non è una figura aristocratica. C'è un commento del Brofferio. È vero che il Brofferio era un
avversario politico. Era un uomo di sinistra, poeta e politico di sinistra, che con Cavour ha
discusso e litigato tutta la vita. Brofferio dice sì sì, mai visto uno meno aristocratico di lui. E,
cito, il volume della persona, il volgare aspetto, il gesto ignobile, la voce ingrata, in più con quella
fatica di dover parlare in italiano, in Parlamento. Ecco, dunque, un quadro contrastante, ma in ogni
caso un nobile, figlio di una grande famiglia nobile, ma, l'ho ricordato un attimo fa, adesso ci
fermiamo un attimo su questo, un figlio cadetto. Ora, essere un figlio cadetto in quella società
significa qualcosa. Anche se formalmente Napoleone ha abolito il maggiorasco, anche se formalmente
le famiglie nobili non avrebbero più il diritto di privilegiare il primo genito, come si faceva
sotto l'antico regime, in realtà non è così, in realtà in queste famiglie il primo genito è quello
che conta e i cadetti devono un po' arrangiarsi. Cavour soffre per tutta la vita questa sua condizione
di cadetto, non sono io a dirlo, sono i suoi stessi parenti. La zia Vittoria, quando è ancora
ragazzino, scrive di Camillo, l'idea di essere cadetto continua a ossessionarlo, non
la può accettare, sarà il tormento della sua vita. Questo essere figlio cadetto ha, tra
le altre conseguenze, come vi dicevo, che Cavour non si sposa, non ha una famiglia sua, vive
per tutta la vita a Palazzo Cavour, dove però il padrone di casa è il fratello maggiore,
Gustavo, con il quale all'inizio si volevano molto bene e più tardi i rapporti si guastano
per ragioni politiche. Ecco, è un dato totalmente privato, può sembrare un aneddoto inutile,
però se vogliamo vedere un uomo a tutto tondo, conta anche questo. Cavour, che per anni è l'uomo
più potente del Piemonte, quando torna a casa, torna in una casa che è sua solo fino a un
certo punto e pranza in compagnia del fratello maggiore, che siede al posto d'onore, Cavour
siede di fianco. A tutti questi pasti assiste l'amministratore della famiglia, favorito dal
fratello Gustavo. Camillo detesta quest'uomo, ma è costretto a pranzare con lui e cenare
con lui tutti i giorni, perché il fratello maggiore lo vuole a tavola. All'inizio c'è
ancora la mamma, c'è il nipote Augusto, c'è un po' più di vita, poi pian piano le persone
muoiono e Cavour si trova negli ultimi anni, appunto, a vivere nel suo appartamento, dentro
il palazzo del fratello, in questa casa che descrive a un amico come, cito, una specie
di succursale del Père Lachaise, cioè del famoso cimitero di Parigi, un posto dove ci
sono solo le memorie di quelli che sono morti e dove non ci si diverte, evidentemente.
Ma al di là dell'aneddoto, il fatto di essere figlio cadetto significa che Cavour deve farsi
strada da solo nella vita, da solo, non che non abbia i suoi privilegi, le conoscenze,
gli agganci, per carità, però ha ben chiaro fin dall'inizio che la sua posizione se la deve
fare. E' certamente anche per questo che ha un carattere ribelle fin dall'inizio.
I litigi col padre, per carità, i litigi col padre avvengono in tutte le famiglie, in tutte
le epoche, in questo caso sono spesso particolarmente violenti. Il padre, il Marchese Michele, che ha
fatto grossi affari sotto il regime napoleonico e appena tornano in Savoia, continua a fare
grossi affari e di nuovo un grosso personaggio di corte, sindaco di Torino, capo della polizia
e così via per anni e anni, quindi uno che stagalla sempre. Bene, il Marchese Michele a
un certo punto è talmente furioso con questo figlio ribelle che prende brutti voti all'Accademia
militare, che minaccia di mandarlo a morire di fame in America. Questa faccenda dell'America
tornerà ed è curioso vedere che già allora, a Piemonte degli anni 20-30, c'era già questa
idea dell'America come il posto dove si mandano quelli senza artene parte, che tanto qui non
riusciamo a sistemarli in nessun modo. Questa ribellione di Cavour però a un certo punto
assume una dimensione politica. Cavour, in contrasto con tutto un ambiente conservatore,
reazionario, sceglie di essere liberale. Ecco, noi oggi rischiamo di non renderci conto che essere
liberale, e cioè desiderare la Costituzione, il Parlamento, le elezioni, la libertà di stampa,
la libertà di associazione. Questo è niente di più, ecco. Noi rischiamo di non renderci conto che nel
Piemonte del giovane Cavour essere liberale poteva sembrare una cosa pericolosamente sovversiva,
pericolosamente di sinistra. L'ambiente in cui nasce e vive Cavour è un ambiente di nobili che
ancora nel 48, voi mi scuserete ancora un paio di citazioni che non sono personali di Camillo,
ma che richiamano l'ambiente in cui lui è vissuto. Ancora nel 48 ci sono nobili che invocano a Torino,
cito, piombo e capestri per contenere quegli insolenti avvocati, sempre gli avvocati, i borghesi
per eccellenza, mercanti e popolani che si credono divenuti qualche cosa. Adesso che c'è stato il 48,
il re ha dato lo statuto, c'è il Parlamento, si vota. C'è un professore all'Università di Torino
che nel 48, vedendo che il re ha dato lo statuto, commenta dove finirà questo paese? Con tanti
germi di liberalismo e democrazia, dove sia ben chiaro che la democrazia è ancora peggio del
liberalismo. Ebbene, in questo Piemonte, nel Piemonte prima del 48, il giovane Camillo passa
per uno pericolosamente di sinistra. E mai collocazione fu più erronea, ben inteso. Però
fa paura, perché è liberale. Il re Carlo Alberto lo definisce a un certo punto un carbonaro
impertinente. Ora di Cavour noi sappiamo che non è mai stato affiliato alla carboneria,
ha sempre detestato Mazzini, le società segrete e così via, ma agli occhi di chi sta dall'altra
parte dello spettro politico, già il suo liberalismo e il ribellismo giovanile lo fanno passare per un
pericoloso cospiratore. Tant'è vero che a 23 anni è già schedato dalla polizia austriaca,
a cui senza dubbio quella piemontese passa le schede, peraltro. È schedato dalla polizia
austriaca la prima volta che deve andare a Milano per affari, a poco più di 20 anni,
ripeto, immediatamente viene fermato e portato in questura a identificarlo, perché è negli
schedari dei pericolosi sovversivi della polizia austriaca. Qui mi verrebbe voglia di fare
una piccolissima parentesi, ma la farò fulminea, sul fatto che a quei tempi, che qualcuno magari
rimpiange, se uno doveva andare da Torino a Milano, doveva procurarsi il passaporto al
Ministero degli Interni e poi veniva fermato alla frontiera, dalla polizia, doveva spiegare
dove andava e perché e poi veniva fermato di nuovo alla barriera doganale, di nuovo spiegare
perché, mostrare il passaporto e così via, ma questo lasciamo stare. Il fatto che Cavour a 23 anni
vada a Milano per affari, mi permette di introdurre un altro aspetto del personaggio
che è un aspetto rilevante. Cavour è un uomo d'affari. Prima di essere un politico è
un uomo d'affari. È un uomo d'affari anche proprio perché è un cadetto e deve farsi
una fortuna, vuole farsi una fortuna sua. Finché c'è il padre, collabora con lui, il
Marchese Michele continua a avere maneggi, business di ogni genere. C'è in particolare
un'occasione che è abbastanza bizzarra perché valga la pena di riferirla. Quando
Cavour ha 26 anni, fa un viaggio d'affari in Austria per conto del padre, va a comprare
pecore merinos perché il padre, il Marchese Michele, è il fornitore di pecore merinos
di Muhammad Ali, pascià d'Egitto. Ecco, la globalizzazione non c'era ancora ma gli affari
si facevano già su grande scala. Il pascià d'Egitto si rivolgeva a Torino per comprare
pecore merinos in Austria e il giovane Camillo si occupa anche di queste cose. Così come
si occupa di borsa. Gioca in borsa, gioca in borsa molto, ogni tanto ha fortuna, ogni
tanto gli va molto male. È un giocatore spericolato, come sarà poi anche tutto sommato
anche in politica. Gioca in borsa e a un certo punto gli va veramente molto male. E a Parigi
ha giocato, gli è andata malissimo, si trova a dover trovare in pochi giorni 45.000 franchi.
Per intenderci, 45.000 franchi all'epoca sono il reddito annuo delle due principali tenute
agricole della famiglia Cavour. Due grandi tenute a riso nel Vercellese, ricchissime.
Ecco, l'intero reddito annuo di queste tenute Cavour se l'è bruciato in borsa con una speculazione
a Parigi e da Parigi scrive al padre, e questo è molto indicativo dello stile di Camillo,
a chi si scrive al padre ovviamente, bisogna pagare o farsi saltare le cervella. E notate
che questa è la prima di diverse volte in cui questa minaccia di farsi saltare le cervella
tornerà fuori nella carriera di Cavour. Più avanti nella vita tornerà fuori per motivi
politici. All'inizio invece è per la speculazione andata male in borsa. Ovviamente il padre lo
salva, trova i soldi e glieli manda. Ma notate, torno ancora su questo punto per l'ultima
volta, Cavour, parrebbe dalla sua corrispondenza, aveva sperato da giovane di farsi rapidamente
un patrimonio per potersi sposare. Si intende, sposarsi a quel livello sociale significa poter
prendere una donna del tuo rango con una dote e poterle garantire un certo stile di vita.
Con il patrimonio di un cadetto non si può. Cavour ci spera e la rovina della sua speculazione
in borsa è anche il momento in cui rinuncia a questo sogno giovanile di farsi una famiglia
sua. Si concentra sugli affari, si concentra sugli affari di famiglia, si interessa di innovazioni
in agricoltura, fa fruttare le grandi tenute risicole del Vercellese, accumula profitti,
diventa grosso azionista di banche, è uno degli uomini più ricchi del regno di Sardegna,
Camillo, dopo qualche anno di speculazioni e di affari. Ha le mani in pasta un po' in tutto,
nel momento in cui diventa ministro dell'agricoltura e commercio, il suo primo incarico ministeriale,
liquida immediatamente quasi tutti i suoi interessi finanziari, industriali, bancari,
dando per scontato che quando uno diventa ministro è ovvio che debba fare una cosa del genere.
Notate che non è particolarmente contento di farlo. Sia chiaro, non siamo in un mondo di anime belle.
Cavour ai soldi ci tiene, alle sue azioni ci tiene, agli affari ci tiene, li fa in modo
spregiudicato finché può. Semplicemente vive in un mondo dove è ovvio che quando diventi
ministro non lo puoi più fare. Poi beninteso, è sempre difficile districare tutto. Si tiene una
cosa sola, la tenuta agricola di Leri, che è la tenuta amatissima nel Vercellese dove lui va a
rifugiarsi nei brutti momenti. Questa tenuta di Leri produce riso e rende. C'è un momento in cui
il conflitto di interessi prende anche Cavour nonostante tutto. È un momento in cui lui ha il
governo e c'è carestia e i prezzi dei cereali salgono e c'è pressione dal basso perché il governo
faccia qualcosa e abbassi il prezzo dei cereali. E Cavour non lo fa. È beninteso, lui non lo fa
soprattutto perché non ci crede. La sua posizione teorica, economica è che il liberismo assoluto è
l'unica cosa possibile. Però è anche vero che più alti sono i prezzi dei cereali e più il suo riso
del Vercellese rende. E quella è forse l'unica occasione in cui a Torino Cavour è fischiato dalla
gente e la gente va a tirar pietre contro le finestre di Palazzo Cavour accusandolo di affamare il
popolo. Per dire che appunto non è così semplice neanche in un'epoca che lo dà per scontato districare
fino in fondo gli affari e la politica. Quello che vorrei sottolineare adesso è che il Cavour uomo
d'affari ed economista è il punto di partenza della sua carriera politica. È come l'economista
più competente del Piemonte che lui a un certo punto viene chiamato al governo, che a un certo
punto diventa evidente a tutti che di un uomo così non si può fare a meno. Ma non è un
economista teorico in senso astratto. Cavour ha una conoscenza approfondita del funzionamento
della società, delle classi sociali, dei salari, dei prezzi. Fin da ragazzo no, ma da giovanotto
ha una conoscenza di queste cose. C'è una cosa significativa. Quando Cavour ha 24 anni, il
governo inglese si sta preparando a varare una serie di leggi sulla povertà, sull'assistenza
ai poveri, sul lavoro obbligatorio per i mendicanti e così via, il complesso delle poor laws, come
le chiamano. Per varare questo insieme di leggi il governo inglese fa una grande inchiesta
in Europa per sapere com'è la condizione dei poveri e degli operai, che sono quasi la
stessa cosa, nei vari paesi europei. L'ambasciatore inglese a Torino si rivolge al sindaco, che è
il papà di Cavour, chiedendogli delle notizie e delle informazioni sulla situazione degli
operai a Torino. Il marchese Michele dice, ma c'è mio figlio, lui queste cose le sa
benissimo. Camillo accetta l'incarico di redigere una memoria, che scrive in francese
e poi pubblica, è la sua prima pubblicazione, a 24-25 anni, una memoria sulla condizione
dei lavoratori in Piemonte, in cui fa un'analisi estremamente realistica e arriva a conclusioni
importanti. Per esempio scopre che basta la minima disgrazia perché un operaio si è
ridotto in miseria e costretto a contrarre debiti. E poi si pone Cavour il problema se
sia possibile per gli operai risparmiare qualcosa. Cavour risponde, ciò mi pare assolutamente
impossibile. Ecco, questa consapevolezza delle condizioni di vita delle masse popolari è
una cosa che accompagnerà Cavour, che ripeto, lo vedremo ancora meglio adesso, non è certo
uno di sinistra, tutt'altro, ma accompagna Cavour e, come dire, dà fondamento alla sua
azione politica in più momenti.
Nel 1848 scoppia per prima cosa la rivoluzione in Francia. Cade la monarchia, c'è la repubblica.
La reazione di Cavour a questa vicenda è interessantissima. Cavour analizza l'opinione
pubblica e scopre che l'opinione pubblica è abbastanza spaventata da questi fatti di
Francia. E dice, eppure è strano perché l'opinione pubblica ormai comincia a essere
illuminata, sono tanti i liberali, i progressisti. Come mai allora la caduta della monarchia, la
repubblica in Francia ha suscitato soprattutto spavento e conclude con questa frase memorabile.
Non sono l'idea di democrazia e di repubblica che spaventano, è lo spettro del comunismo.
Non so se vi rendete conto, siamo nel 1848, cioè precisamente nell'anno in cui esce il
manifesto del partito comunista di Marx e Engels, che comincia con la frase un tempo celeberrima,
ma spero ancora oggi conosciuta, uno spettro si aggira per l'Europa. Ecco, Cavour è uno
abbastanza al corrente di quello che succede, con una capacità di analisi abbastanza sofisticata
del mondo in cui vive, da arrivare a questa stessa immagine dello spettro che si aggira
per l'Europa, nello stesso momento in cui la formulano Marx e Engels. Aveva letto Marx e
Engels, difficile dirlo con certezza. Un'idea però ce l'aveva, infatti prosegue, sempre commentando
il fatto che l'opinione pubblica si è spaventata per i fatti di Francia. Eppure la democrazia
non dispiace troppo, ormai a molti, la Repubblica, molti ormai l'accetterebbero, ma quel che fa
paura è il comunismo. E prosegue. Ognuno si domanda se le dottrine socialiste e comuniste
nate nei cupi cervelli di alcuni filosofi della Germania, eccoli Marx e gli Engels, stanno
per essere tradotte in pratica da quegli ardimentosi francesi. Perché continuo i francesi, si sa,
sono capaci di tutto, lo si è visto nel 1789, ne hanno fatte di tutti i tipi. Adesso chissà
mai che non prendano loro in mente l'idea del comunismo, perché a quel punto siamo fritti.
Cavour continua a seguire questo tema. La Repubblica francese dura tre anni. Nel 51 c'è
il colpo di stato di Luigi Napoleone, il nipotino di Napoleone il Grande. Luigi Napoleone diventa
presidente della Repubblica e poi rapidamente imperatore, con una netta svolta a destra della
politica francese. E Cavour commenta, la paura del socialismo vince nei francesi l'amore della
libertà. Gran lezione. Non riflettiamo magari sul fatto che sono passati 150 anni e sembra
che non sia cambiato molto, ma quello che mi interessa qui è far vedere un Cavour che
appunto è al corrente delle cose più moderne, anzi in qualche modo prefigura anche la politica
ancora di là da venire. Beninteso, Cavour quindi fieramente anticomunista, antirivoluzionario
e così via. Ma quando i tessitori biellesi scioperano, quando le fabbriche di Biella che
sono il principale polo, il primo piccolo polo industriale del Piemonte, entrano in sciopero
e sono i primi scioperi da quelle parti negli anni 50, Cavour che è al governo, risponde
che per prevenire il socialismo, e stavo citando di nuovo, è necessario migliorare i salari
degli operai e migliorare la loro condizione. Addio. Me lo rende poi più piacere? Grazie.
Vabbè, grazie.
Dunque, è necessario migliorare la condizione degli operai? Cito ancora, se no è inevitabile
la guerra sociale. Allora, lucidità politica evidentemente e soprattutto capacità di collocarsi
in una posizione politica, oggi piacerebbe a tanti definirsi centristi, moderati, ecco,
Cavour ha molto chiaro il fatto che ci sono, ha molto chiaro il suo punto di vista chiaramente,
che ci sono due pericoli nella congiuntura drammatica che l'Italia, il regno di Sardegna
e l'Europa stanno vivendo in quel momento. Da una parte c'è il pericolo certo dei rossi,
dell'anarchia, del comunismo, della rivoluzione, ma dall'altra c'è il pericolo della sciabola,
del tintinnar di sciabole, dei governi reazionari, militari che metterebbero fine volentieri alla
libertà di stampa, alle elezioni e così via. E Cavour ha chiarissimo che entrambe le cose,
dal suo punto di vista, sarebbero una tragedia. E si butta in politica. Cavour si butta in
politica nel 48, enunciando chiaramente che c'è bisogno di quello. È necessario, indispensabile,
di costituire un partito liberale conservatore. Perché? Perché a sinistra verrà fuori qualcosa
di forte e bisogna cercare di frenarlo. Dobbiamo aspettarci a vedere costituirsi,
e l'italiano di Cavour naturalmente. Dobbiamo aspettarci a vedere costituirsi un partito
estremo, impaziente. Bisogna apparecchiarsi a combatterlo. E però poi sempre batte, ben
inteso, sul fatto che i pericoli sono due, da due parti. Quando la prima guerra di indipendenza
va a finire molto male, con il disastro di Novara nel 49, e sembra che il Piemonte sia
lì lì per ridiventare reazionario, abolire lo statuto e così via, Cavour dice, qui c'è
il pericolo? Due pericoli di nuovo. Di venire sommersi dalle onde dell'anarchia o incatenati
al potere della sciabola. E invece ci vuole una linea di mezzo che però deve essere una
linea risolutamente riformista. Cito ancora, scusatemi se cito troppo me lo direte, nelle
prossime serate diminuirò le citazioni. Le riforme, è sempre Camillo che parla, compiute
a tempo, invece di indebolire l'autorità, la rafforzano. Invece di crescere la forza
dello spirito rivoluzionario, lo riducono all'impotenza. E dunque Cavour nel 48, a 38
anni, decide, ormai è un uomo ricco, decide che ancora più degli affari gli interessa
la politica. Perché il mondo sta vivendo una stagione straordinaria e lui vuole esserci
dentro e vuole essere uno di quelli che la dirigono questa stagione straordinaria. In
parte è certamente ancora l'ambizione di un carattere straordinario e anche ancora sempre
l'ambizione del cadetto che ha imparato che la sua posizione deve farsela da solo. C'è
un aneddoto molto rivelatore. Una lettera di Cavour, torniamo indietro di qualche anno,
quando aveva 22 anni, Cavour scrive alla Marchesa di Barolo dicendo, con quel tono che si ha a volte
a 22 anni quando si pensa di essere usciti dall'adolescenza, dice, io ormai sono disilluso,
non è più come quando ero ragazzo, cito, quando avrei creduto del tutto naturale risvegliarmi
un bel mattino primo ministro del Regno d'Italia. Ecco, parleremo poi di quanto l'idea di un Regno
d'Italia fosse plausibile, immaginabile al tempo in cui Cavour era giovane. Molti politici
seri, serissimi, avrebbero detto no, figuriamoci, non è nemmeno immaginabile. Cavour a 22 anni
si ricorda che lui da ragazzino, quando sognava a occhi aperti, si vedeva non primo ministro
del Regno di Sardegna, ma primo ministro del Regno d'Italia. Dopodiché appunto nel 48 decide
di entrare in politica, per la via del giornalismo. Un'altra intuizione di Cavour è che la politica
si fa con i mass media, cosa che fino al 48 non era possibile, perché prima dello statuto
non c'era la libertà di stampa. I giornali li controllava la polizia e impediva di pubblicare
qualunque cosa che non andasse bene al governo. Di conseguenza giornali politici non esistevano.
La concessione dello statuto a Torino nel 48 vuol dire anche che di colpo nascono un'infinità
di giornali, giornali politici. Cavour, che ormai i soldi li ha, si fa il suo giornale, che lui
dirige e che, di nuovo con notevole capacità di previsione, intitola il risorgimento. Siamo
appena all'inizio, ma il concetto evidentemente circola già e lui ha già capito che quello
è lo slogan cruciale. Dunque Cavour dirige il risorgimento e in quegli anni, in quei mesi,
in realtà non dura moltissimo mentre la facendo, due o tre anni al massimo, si compiace di essere
un giornalista. Parla di sé come un giornalista, termine che è appena nato all'epoca e che
indica in realtà il direttore di giornale, naturalmente dagli occhi di Camillo, non certo
l'ultimo articolista. E va alle elezioni. Va alle elezioni del 48 per il primo Parlamento
subalpino ed è battuto. Non entra in Parlamento, è furioso. Cito ancora da una sua lettera a un
amico. Oh dura sorte. Solo tra i giornalisti mi trovo escluso dalla Camera. Dopo aver lavorato
nel campo della politica, altrettanto, se non di più di qualunque mio collega giornalista,
sono il solo rigettato dal Paese. Va detto che Cavour non è mai stato uno che prende bene le
sconfitte. Anche in seguito è uno che tende a reagire piuttosto violentemente alle sconfitte.
per fortuna c'è subito un'elezione suppletiva e viene eletto stavolta. Va in Parlamento e ci
resterà per tutti quei 12 anni che gli restano da vivere. 13 nel 48. Dunque entra in Parlamento,
ma il Parlamento è soltanto un gradino. Cavour si sente ed è certamente di una statura tale da
dover essere chiamato al governo. È l'economista più esperto del Regno. Oltre a essere uno degli
uomini più ricchi del Regno, sottolineiamolo, con soldi che si è fatto in gran parte da sé.
Invece, dopo la catastrofe di Novara del 49, si fa il nuovo governo d'Azeglio. Cavour credeva di
essere chiamato al governo, d'Azeglio non lo chiama. Cavour se ne va a Leri, in campagna,
e di nuovo scrive agli amici. Almeno lì avrò la consolazione di vivere come se quella puttana
d'Italia non esistesse. Dove la cosa che ha notato più di tutto è l'Italia, però. Perché
lui vuol diventare ministro del Regno di Sardegna. Hanno appena perso clamorosamente la prima guerra
d'indipendenza. Molti stanno pensando, beh, basta, ci abbiamo provato, è finita. A Cavour è chiarissimo
che l'orizzonte della politica è l'orizzonte dell'Italia. Certo, se è così faticoso servire
l'Italia, ogni tanto viene voglia di mandare tutto il diavolo. Ma sono crisi che passano
rapidamente. Cavour sa molto bene quello che vuole. Aspetta il suo tempo. Finalmente, due anni
dopo, nel 51, D'Azeglio commette l'errore della sua vita e lo chiama al governo. All'inizio D'Azeglio
è contentissimo. Il governo era debole, mancava di individualità forti. Uno come Cavour è proprio
quello che ci vuole. D'Azeglio scrive, sono contentissimo di aver chiamato Cavour. È un autentico
gallo da combattimento. Specialità che ci mancava. Io non mi fermerò durante questa
serata, o quel poco che ne resta, sul Cavour politico capace di padroneggiare i parlamenti
come vuole, sul Cavour che governa anche quando non è al governo, perché non c'è nessuno
nel Paese che abbia un seguito delle clientele, le folle che gli vanno dietro, come le ha lui.
Ecco, non mi fermerò su questo. Ma certamente, appunto, è un gallo da combattimento. È un
politico di razza. D'Azeglio si illude. Il re Vittorio, di cui parleremo molto più
ampiamente domani, ma che facciamo entrare nel nostro racconto adesso, il re Vittorio è
più lucido. Quando D'Azeglio, tutto contento, va a dirgli che ha dato un ministero a Cavour,
il re gli dice. Ma come? Ma non vedono, lor signori, che quell'uomo lì li manderà tutti
con le gambe all'aria. Ma parlava in piemontese e disse di peggio, beninteso. Ecco, il re aveva
perfettamente ragione. Già pochi mesi dopo, quando D'Azeglio si riferisce a Cavour nelle
sue lettere, lo chiama l'empio rivale. Cavour con ogni mezzo si dà da fare, alla fine fa
fuori D'Azeglio, diventa lui il primo ministro ed è il padrone della politica del Regno di
Sardegna per un decennio. Il governo di Cavour corrisponde appunto alla gran parte del decennio
1850 ed è un decennio di stupefacente crescita per l'economia piemontese, Ligure, del Regno
di Sardegna. In parte, in gran parte, questa crescita è anche merito di Cavour, nella misura
in cui la crescita economica dipende dai governi, ma noi viviamo in un'epoca in cui si dà per
scontato che i governi possano fare delle cose, debbano intervenire per sostenere l'economia.
Bene, certamente Cavour questo lo sapeva e lo faceva. La caratteristica dominante del
Cavour che governa l'economia è la fede nella modernizzazione, che risale anche lì a quando
era giovane, a quando ha 25 anni è andato in viaggio in Inghilterra e ha fatto questa
esperienza formativa decisiva, è andato in treno da Liverpool a Manchester, 1835, 50
chilometri in un'ora e mezza. Una di quelle esperienze che cambiano un modo di vedere il
mondo. Da quel momento Camillo ha un cardine fermissimo. Progresso, modernizzazione, infrastrutture,
ferrovie, ferrovie, ferrovie, porti, ferrovie, strade, ferrovie, canali, trafori e ferrovie
naturalmente. Tutto questo costerà moltissimo, certo, costerà moltissimo. Bisogna che il Paese
diventi via via più ricco per potersi permettere tutto questo. Il Paese diventerà più ricco
se si aboliscono le tariffe, le barriere doganali. L'altro pilastro del Cavour economista e politico
è il libero scambio. Abolire tutto, lasciar circolare le merci e la ricchezza affluirà
da sé. Ebbene, Cavour fa questa scommessa nel momento giusto. Forse in un'altra epoca
storica non gli sarebbe andata così bene, ma quelli sono i decenni della grande crescita
economica di tutta Europa. E il Piemonte è la parte d'Italia che è meglio attrezzata
per le idee di chi governa, intendo, per inserirsi all'ultimo momento in questo colossale movimento
di crescita. Gli anni 50 sono un momento sbalorditivo in cui, appunto, si costruiscono
ferrovie. Nel 1860 il Piemonte ha una rete ferroviaria che è pari a metà dell'intera
rete italiana. Si costruiscono canali, il canale Cavour, tuttora in uso. Si aprono i
lavori per il traforo del Freius, tuttora in uso. Nascono la rete telegrafica, l'illuminazione
a gas, nuove banche, la borsa di Torino. Ben inteso, tutto questo avviene anche altrove, dove
i governi hanno capito che questo movimento bisogna sostenerlo. Ci sono altre zone d'Italia
dove invece questo viene fatto molto meno. I risultati sono spettacolari. La crescita
dell'economia del Regno di Sardegna nel decennio di Cavour è sbalorditiva a livelli cinesi,
cinesi di oggi. In quel decennio le esportazioni triplicano. Il reddito nazionale complessivo
si raddoppia in dieci anni. Ben inteso, tutto questo però non si paga da sé. Tutto
questo richiede una fortissima capacità di investimento e di spesa da parte di Cavour.
E qui va detto che il Cavour, assolutamente liberista, che non crede alle dogane, alle
tariffe, ai prezzi imposti artificialmente e così via, però crede fermamente nella spesa
pubblica. E sostiene, negli anni del suo governo, una colossale spesa pubblica. E dunque
aumenta le tasse. Cavour nei suoi anni di governo e di splendore è temuto e odiato
anche da qualcuno come quello che sta facendo pagare un sacco di tasse a quelli che prima
non le pagavano. Il sistema fiscale fino a quel momento era ancora un sistema di antico
regime sostanzialmente basato sulla terra. Chi ha la terra paga le imposte. Le professioni
per esempio praticamente non pagavano. Cavour fa pagare le tasse agli avvocati, ai medici.
Ci sarà qualcosa del nobile che tutto sommato conserva un po' di antipatia verso questa gente,
questi borghesi ed è ben contento di far pagare anche loro? Chi lo sa? Ma certamente
in Parlamento c'è chi protesta e nel Paese corrono le canzonette satiriche. Io mi sono
chiesto a lungo se avrei provato a accennarvi il ritornello qui, poi ho deciso che non lo farò
ed è meglio per voi. Tuttavia corrono le canzonette satiriche in cui il ritornello è appunto
cacciate fuori i scudi e viva il magnifico conte di Cavour, il tutto in piemontese si intende.
Ora però questa colossale crescita economica non è fine a se stessa. Nella prospettiva di Cavour è
evidente che le sfide dell'Italia, della Sardegna, del Piemonte e dell'Italia sono da un lato la
modernizzazione economica e dall'altro la liberazione del Paese dalle ingerenze straniere, poi anche
l'unità. Se abbiamo tempo ci arriveremo, ma questo passa un po' in secondo piano a dir la verità
all'inizio. La prima cosa è la liberazione di quelle parti d'Italia che appartengono a potenze
straniere, il Lombardo-Veneto-Austriaco essenzialmente. Ecco, da questo punto di vista Cavour ha ben
chiaro che la modernizzazione del Paese significa anche un passo in quella direzione. Le ferrovie da
sole, per il solo fatto che fanno spostare la gente, sono un passo in quella direzione. Già nel
1845, non è ancora al governo, a 35 anni, è un economista noto, scrive un articolo per una rivista
svizzera, in cui dice che le ferrovie favoriranno lo spirito di nazionalità italiana, proprio per il
solo fatto che produrranno un incessante movimento di persone in tutte le direzioni, in quell'Italia
che in gran parte all'epoca ha ancora strade impraticabili, briganti che le minacciano e così
via. Questo articolo è scritto per una rivista svizzera, è un articolo che parla di treni, come
vedete, di ferrovie, di ferrovie che favoriranno la nazionalità italiana e il suo sviluppo. Il
direttore del giornale svizzero non lo pubblica, dice, è proprio pericoloso politicamente un
articolo del genere. Non ho letto finora niente di più profondamente ostile alla dominazione
austriaca in Italia. E dunque veniamo al tema di quello che Cavour ha fatto negli ultimi anni
del suo governo. La guerra del 59, l'annessione della Lombardia e poi dei principati e così via,
la nascita del Regno d'Italia e poi il sostegno, vedremo quanto questa parola possa essere adatta,
all'impresa di Garibaldi. Per orientarci in quest'ambito, scusatemi, sottolineo ancora che di
questo tema parleremo assai meglio domani e ancora meglio dopodomani affrontando la figura
di Garibaldi. Qui io potrò cominciare soltanto a fare alcuni accenni su questo. Per affrontare
questo tema io mi sono fatto l'idea che è fondamentale avere chiari i due livelli di
obiettivi che i liberali italiani si ponevano all'epoca. L'ho già accennato prima, ma diciamolo
di nuovo. C'è un obiettivo su cui tutti sono d'accordo. Il Paese per progredire deve essere
libero, non ci devono essere parti dell'Italia che appartengono a imperi stranieri. Essenzialmente
vuol dire una cosa sola, il Lombardo-Veneto fuori gli austriaci. Su questo i liberali italiani
e a maggior ragione i democratici sono tutti d'accordo. L'altro problema è diverso. È
il problema se un giorno sarà possibile un'Italia unita. Un'Italia unita vuol dire naturalmente
che tante piccole dinastie dovranno essere fatte sparire, che tante piccole indipendenze
andranno abolite per creare un Paese unito. Questo secondo punto è nell'aria, se ne parla,
gli appassionati ci credono, ma la gente con i piedi per terra come Cavour per molto tempo
non ci crede affatto. Ancora pochissimi anni prima che tutto precipiti con l'impresa di
Garibaldi e che si arrivi davvero all'Italia unita, Cavour a un certo punto, in un congresso
in cui si discute di queste cose, dice apertamente che l'idea dell'Italia unita è una corbelleria.
Ben inteso, non che non sia una cosa desiderabile. Questo è lo stesso uomo che da ragazzino diceva
che sognava di essere il primo ministro del Regno d'Italia. Tutti dicono in teoria sarebbe
desiderabile, ma il realismo politico sembrava imporre di andarci cauti. Quanto invece a buttare
fuori gli austriaci? Su questo certamente se ne può discutere. E poi c'è anche un problema
intermedio. L'Italia unita magari è impossibile, ma ci sono dinastie, io ragiono adesso come
ragionavano Cavour e gli uomini del suo partito e gli uomini delle sue idee, sia chiaro. Ci
sono dinastie in Italia che sono comunque impresentabili, che hanno una tale immagine
all'estero che è impossibile pensare di continuare così, in particolare quella borbonica
nel mezzogiorno. La dinastia borbonica è universalmente ritenuta in tutta Europa così
arretrata, reazionaria, impresentabile, ripeto, per opinione comune di tutti i governi, i giornali,
l'opinione pubblica, che il problema di in qualche modo liberarsi dei borboni è assolutamente
presente anche a Cavour, anche nel momento in cui però l'idea poi di unificare dopo l'Italia
sembra assurda. E allora qual è la soluzione? Il fatto è che ancora in quegli anni, gli anni
tra la prima e la seconda guerra di indipendenza, la diplomazia europea ragiona ancora abbastanza
in termini vecchi, nei termini di quella politica dinastica che si faceva nel Settecento. Avete
presente quelle guerre in cui il problema era soltanto se un borbone diventava re di Spagna
oppure no, la guerra appunto di successione spagnola, austriaca? Ecco, è abbastanza impressionante
vedere come anche in un'epoca che noi penseremmo più vicina alla nostra, la metà dell'Ottocento,
in realtà i governi e le diplomazie ragionavano ancora abbastanza in questi termini. E quindi
era tutto un discorrere di scambi. I borboni per esempio sono impresentabili, è vero, se
potessimo toglierli, chi ci mettiamo? Qualcun altro al loro posto, bisogna fare degli spostamenti.
questo viene fuori in modo straordinario al congresso di Parigi del 1856. C'è stata
la guerra di Crimea. Cavour ha ottenuto che il regno di Sardegna partecipasse alla guerra
di Crimea per stringere un legame di amicizia con la Francia e con l'Inghilterra, sempre
in vista un giorno di buttare fuori gli austriaci dall'Italia, in vista di una guerra in cui
sarà necessario il sostegno della Francia e dell'Inghilterra. Alla fine della guerra di
Crimea si fa un bel congresso a Parigi per ridisegnare la mappa d'Europa. Ed è qui
che si vede proprio questa mentalità dei politici, dei diplomatici, per cui si ragiona ancora in
termini di dinastie. È la prima volta che io ho incontrato in cui Cavour discute apertamente,
ufficialmente, del fatto che i borboni da Napoli bisognerebbe buttarli fuori. A Napoli c'è
Ferdinando II, il re bomba, e Cavour a un certo punto scrive, sì, domani vedo il
ministro degli esteri inglese, cito, credo di potergli parlare di gettare in aria il
bomba. E poi una volta gettato in aria cosa si fa? Beh, per esempio se ci fosse un principe
Sabaudo, un cugino del re Vittorio che potesse prendere il trono di Napoli, magnifico, no?
Ecco, sul momento a Parigi l'idea non piace troppo, viene fermata, ma discutono di tante
altre cose. C'è il Ducato di Parma, il Piemonte ha partecipato alla guerra di
Cremea, bisognerà pur dare qualcosa ai Savoia. Ai Savoia piacerebbe moltissimo il Ducato
di Parma. E Napoleone III dice a Cavour, trovate un posto qualunque dove mandare la Duchessa
di Parma e io farò dare il suo Ducato al Piemonte. E Vittorio scrive da Torino a Cavour,
che sta a Parigi a trattare, a negoziare, stanno negoziando anche su certi principati
danubiani, la Transilvania, la Moldavia, che devono essere dati o all'Austria o qualcun
altro. E Vittorio scrive a Cavour, secchi l'imperatore finché basti, dia i principati
all'Austria e anche al diavolo se li vuole, ma si faccia dare quello che voglio, cioè
Parma per l'appunto. Poi alla fine non va in porto niente, Parma non l'ottengono, bisognerà
aspettare il 59-60, ma è per far vedere come queste diplomazie si muovono ancora molto
a livello appunto di dinastie, di una politica dinastica. È in questa prospettiva di incontri
di diplomazie che Cavour a un certo punto comincia a sentire che ha fra le mani qualcosa di grosso.
Dopo la Crimea, la Francia di Napoleone III sta cominciando a accettare l'idea che forse
effettivamente non sarebbe male dare una mano al Piemonte, far guerra all'Austria e buttare
l'Austria fuori dall'Italia. Nel 58 i colloqui sono ormai abbastanza approfonditi, per cui
Cavour è ormai abbastanza sicuro. Napoleone III si è compromesso, gli ha scritto, gli ha
detto va bene, facciamolo. Cavour scrive al ministro della guerra, alla marmora, prepara
i cannoni e l'anno prossimo andremo in parata a Milano, se non a Venezia. Dopodiché c'è uno
dei momenti più drammatici della carriera di Cavour, perché alla fine del 58 Napoleone
III cambia idea. Non è più convinto di questa guerra contro l'Austria, comincia a dire che
sarebbe meglio risolvere tutti questi litigi con un bel congresso, invitare gli austriaci
a discutere con loro e intanto disarmare gli eserciti, che è quello che gli austriaci chiedono.
Quando Cavour si rende conto che tutto il progetto sta cominciando a sgretolarsi, si sente
finito, perché si è compromesso fino in fondo questa idea di fare la guerra all'Austria
con l'aiuto dei francesi. La reazione di Cavour è molto indicativa. Uno, minaccia di
andarsene in America. E due, e poi quando sarà in America dice, io qui ho tutte le lettere
di Napoleone III, in cui mi diceva, sì facciamolo, guarda che vado in America e poi rendo pubbliche
le trattative e voglio vedere la faccia di Napoleone III a quel punto. I francesi sono
lì che non sanno bene cosa fare, il momento è molto teso, c'è da perderci la testa e
infatti Cavour scrive a un amico proprio questo, dice, è difficile non perdere la testa, me
la tengo di quando in quando con le mani perché non fugga. Finalmente tutto sembra perduto,
viene a svegliarlo l'ambasciatore francese e gli dice non c'è niente da fare. L'imperatore
Napoleone III ha deciso che la guerra non la vuol fare, che vuol fare il congresso. Cavour
salta sul letto. Ora non mi resta altro da fare che spararmi un colpo di pistola e farmi
saltare la testa. E due, ce ne sono altre, ma insomma... Però sono momenti di scoraggiamento
e io li cito non solo perché è divertente vedere le reazioni così emotive di un uomo che
a prima vista potrebbe sembrare così freddo a guardare i suoi ritratti e che invece era
chiaramente un uomo fortemente passionale, violento, ecco. E le cito anche per far vedere
che quest'uomo è stato più volte sul punto di disperare e giocava una partita politica
di una difficoltà estrema e però si è sempre ripreso e sempre prevalso alla fine l'entusiasmo,
l'entusiasmo anche gioioso, la certezza che ce la facciamo. Gli vengono a dire che l'Inghilterra,
pure l'Inghilterra è contraria e lui qui ha uno scatto. Non ci sarà Inghilterra che
possa impedirci di andare a bruciare Vienna. Noi metteremo il fuoco all'Europa. Ecco forse
il vecchio Carlo Alberto che diceva sì, un carbonaro impertinente, insomma qualcosa aveva
colto. A forza di insistere, a forza di tenere duro, di tenersi ferma la testa con le mani
perché non voli via, a forza di ricattare, Cavour riesce a convincere Napoleone III che
ormai non può più tirarsi indietro, che questa guerra all'Austria bisogna farla e dunque
la guerra si fa. Io qui però vorrei, sto arrivando alla fine ben inteso, lo dico per gli organizzatori
che saranno già preoccupati, ma vorrei sottolineare ancora un aspetto. Finora noi parliamo del
Cavour politico che tratta con Napoleone III, che tratta con i ministri, parliamo di una
politica fatta in apparenza sopra le teste della gente. In realtà non è così. Questa
è la politica di gabinetto fatta dagli uomini di potere che in ogni epoca esiste naturalmente
e che noi storici oggi possiamo raccontare quando si tratta dell'Ottocento perché abbiamo
le lettere, abbiamo i diari. Gli storici del futuro racconteranno la politica di potere
degli anni 2000 perché forse avranno le lettere e i diari dei potenti di oggi, ma al di là
di questa politica di gabinetto la politica della trattativa, del negoziato, dell'intrigo,
del ricatto, della complicità e dei disegni colossali che però ne vengono fuori, c'è l'opinione
pubblica, ci sono le masse, ci sono i giornali che in un paese liberale come il Piemonte di
allora continuamente seguono l'azione del governo, la denunciano, la criticano, c'è il Parlamento
dove bisogna andare a rispondere e c'è, ripeto, l'opinione pubblica e i popoli. È un tema
delicato quello di quanto i popoli siano stati coinvolti nel Risorgimento, però io
qui vorrei citare soltanto una battuta di Cavour, quando appunto si tratta del fatto che ormai
si è suscitata questa idea che si farà la guerra all'Austria e c'è evidentemente un
entusiasmo popolare per questa idea e gli dicono no, non si fa più. E Cavour dice io non posso
trattare le popolazioni come le comparse in teatro e farle uscire o dentrare a capriccio e
dunque al di sotto dei politici che tramano le popolazioni ci sono e come. E dunque la
guerra si fa, si vince e poi di nuovo c'è apparentemente una catastrofe inattesa. La guerra
si è vinta, sono entrati a Milano, hanno sconfitto gli austriaci, a Magenta, poi a
Solferino e San Martino, si potrebbe continuare, Garibaldi ha quasi conquistato Trento e invece
Napoleone III decide, stavolta sì, che adesso basta però, che non ha più interesse politico
a continuare, che gli basta aver indebolito l'Austria, aver rafforzato il Piemonte, ma basta
la Lombardia, il Veneto, non c'è nessun bisogno di aggiungere anche il Veneto e quindi
Napoleone III firma l'armistizio di Villa Franca con l'Austria e il re Vittorio, anche
se poi dirà che lui c'era rimasto malissimo, però di fatto anche lui dice sì dai ci fermiamo,
abbiamo già fatto un bel boccone, può bastarci. Quando Cavour viene informato di quello che
è successo, se non muore in quel momento è un miracolo, si precipita dal re e c'è
una scena famosa, una scenata famosa tra Cavour e il re, in cui quando Cavour esce,
quelli che lo vedono hanno poi testimoniato che sembrava quasi uscito di senno e il re Vittorio
ha poi riferito che durante quella scenata Cavour, il suo primo ministro, ha preso a calci
le sedie, lo ha chiamato traditore, è peggio, Cavour al re, per aver accettato l'armistizio,
ha minacciato di dimettersi e ha anche detto se un ministro deve sapere quando è ora di
dimettersi, un re deve sapere quando è ora di abdicare.
Cavour effettivamente si dimette, il re, ne riparleremo domani, ormai è quasi il turno
di Vittorio, il re, devo dire, tira un sospiro di sollievo perché lavorare con Cavour non
era proprio facile, scrive a Napoleone III, il re Vittorio, che a questo punto pagherebbe
un milione di franchi purché Camillo partisse per l'America, e tre. Camillo quanto a lui
dice a un amico, mi accorgo che per me è cominciata la vecchiaia, non ha 50 anni in quel
momento. Lo richiamano al governo subito, provano in tutti i modi a fare un altro governo,
senza Cavour non c'è nessuna maggioranza, non c'è nessun governo possibile, lo richiamano
al governo. Fa in tempo a seguire la vicenda di Garibaldi, che non vi racconterò stasera
perché invece io non faccio in tempo a raccontarla stasera, e poi è meglio raccontarla dal
punto di vista di Garibaldi, anche il ruolo di Cavour lo vedremo dopo domani. Fa in tempo
a vedere Garibaldi, a vedere con grandissima sorpresa che sta andando tutto bene, fa in tempo
a vedere l'Italia unita, e poi gli viene una strana febbre all'improvviso, nessuno sa bene
cos'è una febbre altissima, per qualche giorno, oggi si dice che sia malari, che sia
stata un attacco di malaria, forse presa nelle sue risaie del Vercellese, lo riesumeranno
fra poco credo, per esaminare i resti e vedere se effettivamente questa ipotesi è attendibile,
certamente gli viene una febbre tremenda e in pochi giorni muore, a 51 anni. E sulla morte
di Cavour io vorrei citare due testimonianze dell'epoca, voi mi scuserete. La Marchesa
d'Azeglio, che scrive al figlio, che non è a Torino, si piangeva ovunque, non è un modo
di dire, si piangevano lacrime autentiche, si piangeva al Senato, alla Camera, nei Ministeri,
Hudson, che è l'ambasciatore inglese a Torino, piangeva come un bambino.
Un'altra da un diplomatico francese, Henri de Deville, che era un segretario, un aggiunto
dell'ambasciata francese a Torino.
Il conte di Cavour è morto stamattina alle sei e tre quarti. Alle sette mi hanno svegliato
per darmi la notizia. Sono uscito immediatamente. La costernazione e lo stupore che regnano
nella città hanno qualcosa di spaventoso. Tutti i negozi sono chiusi. Gli abitanti circolano
senza sapere dove vanno, col viso sconvolto, interrogandosi e parlando tra loro dell'orribile
disgrazia. Più d'uno si rifiuta di credere alla notizia e si reca al Palazzo per averne
conferma. All'una la Camera e il Senato si sono riuniti per ascoltare la comunicazione
del Governo. Il Ministro dell'Interno, Minghetti, è scoppiato in lacrime annunziando la morte
del Conte Camillo di Cavour, Presidente del Consiglio. Moltissimi deputati piangevano.
Uscendo dalla Camera ho incontrato Sir James, è sempre Hudson il Ministro inglese, che mi
ha stretto la mano senza pronunciare parola. Piangeva a calde lacrime. Ecco, io vorrei
concludere riflettendo su questo mondo, su quest'epoca in cui si piangeva, in cui un
Ministro degli Interni non aveva paura di piangere in Parlamento dando una notizia come
quella, in cui un ambasciatore di sua maestà britannica non aveva paura di piangere davanti
a un diplomatico francese per la strada di fronte a una notizia come quella. Sotto quell'aspetto
erano uomini che avevano un'emotività diversa dalla nostra. Io non ricordo di avere visto
primi ministri piangere oggi anche dando le peggiori notizie. Erano diversi da noi e noi
quando cerchiamo, quando pretendiamo di capirli, pretendere di capirli è giusto, cerchiamo
di capirli e magari pretendiamo anche di giudicarli. Ebbene, dobbiamo ricordare che sotto questo
aspetto almeno erano diversi da noi. Avevano un'emotività diversa dalla nostra, questi uomini
che hanno vissuto e che hanno fatto il risorgimento. A me ogni tanto dispiace un po' che noi oggi
non siamo più come loro. Grazie.